so yesterday we heard Jeff Lichtman give
a beautiful talk and I love looking at
those pictures probably all of us do and
he he emphasized the value of looking at
data and trying not to impose too many
preconceptions you know before you can
really absorb all of the stuff that's
really there so he he almost cautioned
against abstracting away or at least not
doing it too early so this talk is
really kind of you know the pendulum has
swung to the opposite pole and and might
be called abstractions gone wild we're
gonna try to come at this the way an
engineer computer scientist would come
at come-come with a problem that this is
one of the problems that's fascinated me
for many years these are neurons
different different ones from different
areas this is a neuron a motor neuron
from the spinal cord this is a pyramidal
neuron the kind that the Jeff Lichtman
showed a lot of data from those very
detailed dendrite pictures this is a
Purkinje cell in the cerebellum and so
on and what you if you're like me and I
think many of you probably have a
similar kind of spirit of coming from an
engineering or computer science
background you first thing you ask
yourself when you look at a picture like
this as well what is this neuron do and
you know what is its what how would you
describe it if you had to build it or if
you if it's sitting inside a circuit and
you need to know what it's how it's
working you know what is that function
of that thing and why are there
different why are there different shapes
and sizes and morphologies does that
mean that they have different functions
this this came up yesterday do we have
you know a few or do we have a thousands
or 10,000 different types of neurons
that where each time we look at a neuron
we're starting over from scratch and
trying to figure out what it is or is
there just a few oh you know that so
that's the kind of question that we'd
like to get the answer to if you have
any hope of understanding what the brain
is and how it works so I'm going to talk
about this subject in ways that that we
have tried to bring kind of engineering
up
approaches to help answer this really a
scientific question what is a neuron do
and I just as a prelude I only yesterday
kind of and you know between yesterday
and today think that we can at least
firmly say that the answer is it's more
than one type of drug to at least I'm
gonna I'll make an argument for that so
let's let's delve in to what what kind
of question we even want to ask kind of
you know what's the first question that
we would ask in order to move towards
understanding a neuron so this is a
pyramidal neuron it's something that I
have focused on in the work that we do
in my lab here's the cell body it's a
pyramid shaped thing these are called
basal dendrites these these branches
that maybe go a couple hundred microns
so a millimeter would be like you know
this this this could be two millimeters
something like that so these green
things are the dendrites basal dendrites
these are this is called the apical
dendrite this fat thing is the apical
trunk this is called the apical tuft it
reaches up to the top of the cortex so
this is almost the entire thickness of a
cortex this is sitting in layer five and
this red thing is the axon or just the
local bit of this axon which kind of
branches around in each of these little
dots is representing a synaptic contact
with another pyramidal Norwell with
another neuron we don't know what type
of neuron it is you can't see that here
that's the kind of thing the connectome
would would tell us of course this axon
would have more contacts farther away
that were just not captured you know
filling this particular cell and so the
if i zoom it on the dendrite here I can
you can see this these spines this is a
picture from Kristin Harris a TM
reconstruction done many years ago that
the branches are covered with these
spiny protrude rinses these are the
places we're excited to her contacts
lanters the zoom of that and if I were
to modernize this picture I would
we put that in there maybe you've got
you guys that there's really great
videos this is biology died or something
like that where he has he talks about
this and has lots of nice pictures like
we saw yesterday so there's a lot of
detail in here but basically the
contacts the excitatory contacts to
pyramidal neurons land on spines on
these on these branches and a cell of
this size might have 10,000 or 20,000
contacts excitatory contacts Maria if I
say anything wrong you correct me i but
and and of course the axon will make
tens of thousands of contacts on on its
targets some of these inputs to the cell
would be not excitatory they would be
inhibitory they do not typically land on
the spines like like Jeff was showing
all these little red spines sticking out
from the branches but they would land on
the shafts of the dendrites and tend to
be theirs tends to be a concentration of
inhibitory synapses near the cell body
you know too and and and I'm not going
to talk much about that but they there's
not a symmetry between excitation and
inhibition like there isn't an
artificial neural network where a weight
could be positive or negative it's
different neurons and they target the
the primary cells in the in the brain in
very different ways excitation and
inhibition
that's something actually worth keeping
in mind as you think about abstracting
neurons and relating them to artificial
neural neuromorphic architectures and so
on so then what is the problem well the
problem is this neuron is being
activated it it will it can expect in
its daily operations to have what we
don't know it could be dozens it could
be hundreds of contacts these excitatory
contacts being activated simultaneously
and each of them would be being driven
by action potential at well action
potentials are coming down other guys
axons they land they released
neurotransmitter on these spines but
typically not just single time that you
can have bursts or trains of action
potentials that are coming in over time
to particular spines on this on this
neuron delivering excitation these are
currents that are injected into the cell
which are excitatory which push the
membrane potential of the cells towards
you know up from rest towards the
in the direction which will promote
firing of the neuron so those inputs are
coming across the neuron in space and
time across the dendritic tree and then
of course at the same time there's going
to be inhibitory contacts that are being
activated both in the dendrites but also
near the cell body on the axon and so on
that somehow push the cell away well
probably in most cases push the cell
away from a tendency to fire and there's
some kind of arithmetic that allows this
neuron order that this neuron uses to
combine all of these inputs to
eventually turn it into a train of
action potentials that's the output of
of the neuron and that's the one output
of the neuron so that's all anybody else
gets to see is this and we typically
abstract this as a rate now that's not
valid by all any means in all cases but
it is typically abstracted as a rate so
there's a number of action potentials
per second that's being produced by this
cell I know that I'm sure there are
people squirming in their seat and
saying that's that's that's not that
inadequate but that's what I'm gonna
assume just for a conversation right now
so what is the what is the rule that you
use if you wanted to predict what this
neuron would do and that's actually
something that I would say is a
long-term goal of mine I would love and
and I think we can actually do this I
would love to be able to have you come
in here and indicate where the the let
synaptic contacts you are interested in
activating and and put little dots down
and tell me what trains are coming in to
those synapses what what patterns of
stimulation you're delivering it to
which places at which times on this cell
excitation and inhibition and then have
me be able to take your input and and
tell you like on a piece of paper like
look up at my little black book and
literally without a computer and within
a minute be able to tell you how the
neuron will respond to that like how
many spikes per second I actually
believe that this is possible to do and
I'm almost want to set up a contest to
see if we you know to see who could
predict and you know with a pencil and
paper and maybe a few a few tables what
the what the firing rate of the neuron
will be so that's the goal because if
you could do that then it means you
really understand what the neuron
what the neuron is any questions so far
good question why pencil on paper as
opposed to a computer well if you could
do with a pencil and paper it means it's
really simple so you've boiled it down
to something that requires the minimum
amount of stuff to compute it or to
represent what the computation is you
know we can throw this into a
compartmental model that has a thousand
compartments tens of thousands of
differential equations do numerical
integration of thousands and thousands
of time steps is all really nonlinear
and then count you know voltage spikes
coming out or if you could do it with a
pencil and paper in one minute it knows
you've captured something but it means
you've captured something and that's the
kind of thing that we'd like to capture
the most compact description that we can
that that doesn't you know it's as
simple as possible but no simpler right
[Music]
how many parameters do you need to
approximate it well enough like
conductivity length something like that
there are there well that is a great
question and it's exactly the spirit of
this this entire presentation is you
know how many parameters but also what
are the parameters that you would need
to describe this neuron and what we hope
and you know Geoff's are kind of you
know the way that you know we see these
pictures and you go my god it's just
this incredible picture that was just
stuff and it looks really really
complicated but we all accept that if we
understand what this dendrite is and
does and describe it then when we want
to get to this dendrite we're gonna be
well along the way to understanding that
one - its - this it's probably the
identical device essentially but just
with different stuff connecting up to it
this is we have to have some faith that
there is some repetition of you know and
of course I believe that I mean I admit
it that this neuron of the neuron that
is right next to it will be the same you
know we have to be careful but there
will be but that's the right question
how many parameters do we need to
describe let's say one
fine one branch one neuron etc that's
exactly the spirit of this of this
presentation good question one way that
you can do it is you can set up parallel
experiments and model tests so you can
experiments can be done and I'll show
you a couple where a real neuron is
stimulated and say a brain slice in a
certain way and a prediction is made and
tested and so on that's one way to do it
see if you you know when you see that
see if you find that satisfactory okay
let me move on here okay this is really
kind of something that we just cover
quickly how complicated a model we may
be that's that's kind of what we were
just talking about to think about neuron
models as they they're kind of in a two
dimensional space one of them is where
you go from simple to complicated
morphology and one is when you go to
simple to complicated dynamics and
things that we're familiar with will fit
on this graph so for example a
perceptron McCulloch Pitts and our on or
a unit in a neural network a rectified
linear unit or some big falls over here
we don't have a morphology there's no
dendrites and there's no no dynamics
it's just adds up weighted inputs and
then puts it through some kind of a
non-linearity if you go to this corner
you have like an is your Kevin neuron
it's an integrated fire neuron that
represents like the ion channels that
generate action potentials but it
doesn't it still doesn't have any
morphology to it if you go to this
corner you have something that is an
abstraction that includes say dendritic
morphology but maybe continues to have a
simple rule non dynamical that was not
described by differential equations rule
for integrating inputs and in this
corner would be a detailed compartmental
model which is just trying to reproduce
what the neuron actually is on the
computer you know with all of the
physical stuff in it cables channels
capacitance you know everything that you
would have in a real neuron so that you
can kind of replicate it and do an
experiment on that thing so that would
be just like what you might do on a real
neurons
and then also we can abstract in
different amounts the output code of a
neuron and as I said we're going to talk
about a rate code and almost exclusively
today but it might be that the output
code needs to be discussed in terms of
individual spikes that come out at
individual times and that's a perfectly
valid thing to to want to do in certain
situations so the answer is it depends
on which neuron and actually fortunately
those are the very two neurons I didn't
mean to do that that I'm gonna mention
as having different very different
descriptions and also probably what
scenario the neuron is being used in it
might change how we would want to model
the neuron because the neuron might the
same neuron might be used in different
ways so I I'm going to be focusing on
this kind of part of the space where we
have morphologically faithful
representations of the neuron but with
simplified dynamics and also simplifying
rate code some playing the output
described it as a rate come okay now
what so most of history in neuroscience
this is the point neuron has been the
model of choice or not or I should say
the default way of thinking about a
neuron
I pulled pictures out of kind of
well-known papers that make this point
this is from Hubel and Wiesel paper
simple cells in the complex cell these
are okay they're not always drawn as
round shapes but basically you don't see
dendrites in these pictures so the cells
are typically represented or a thought
about in terms of a thing which sums and
combines all the inputs in one place and
then there's a number that is produced
or an action potential is produced or an
output that is produced at that place so
this is a neuron and and it receives or
let's see where can I show you one these
neurons receive inputs from a couple of
sources and then they fire don't fire
then they drive other neurons and so on
so dendrites have disappeared completely
from the pictures of most models in most
papers over most of history and I I've
heard somebody once say well you know it
used to be in the old days when qahal
was doing this you know he would draw
these beautiful things but you know if
he wanted to publish a paper and you it
was just took up too much space to draw
the dendrites and so people stopped
doing it and then they kind of forgot
about him or and there wasn't a way to
study dendrites in the old days the
techniques for recording from dendrites
and imaging dendrites didn't exist so
they kind of fell out of use and people
it's very much pushed the experimental
side of the field towards thinking about
neurons in as point neurons summing
devices essentially with a threshold
attached now here's something that I
just wanted to add because it really
relates to this this issue of
abstraction and what what how you have
to be careful what you how you interpret
what you see and how influenced you are
by what you see and how complicated
things look so this cell the Purkinje
cell is arguably the most intricate
dendritic tree in the brain these
fan-shaped dendrites are extremely
elaborate and hierarchical you know it's
got many levels of branching so maybe
this is five or six or however many
layers of levels of a tree and these
also are the prizewinners for a number
of contacts the typical Purkinje cell
may receive 100,000 or 200,000 contacts
synaptic contacts from other neurons
they come through perpendicular to the
dendritic tree again these are kind of
fan-shaped entrance so they come through
and they make contacts they're like one
over 200,000 so it's really important to
know what's the rule for combining
100,000 inputs to one neuron and it
could be very complicated this is just a
more modern picture of a Purkinje cell
and i throw in one more modern picture
well you can zoom in can i zoom it in
here and I don't know if I can well
anyway you can see there's just this
incredibly intricate sort of twigs you
know that had that are covered densely
with spines it's they're really
unbelievably prodigious collectors of of
input so what is the what is the what is
what is known about this well
interestingly so this is from the
cerebellum the cerebellum is that thing
sticking out the back here that kind of
has a cauliflower like look to it this
is the cerebellar cortex all I'll kind
of crumpled up and if you look at one of
these crumples here's where the Purkinje
cells are they kind of have their own
separate spaces and the inputs are
coming in
perpendicular as I show that that's
these red these red wires so the way
this works is that the inputs to the
kind of the informational inputs come in
to this layer of extremely dense granule
cells which apparently act like little
feature detectors little conjunctions of
a few four to seven inputs these little
red cells are granule cells and they
kind of conjoined or make it like a you
know literally a conjunction something
like a conjunction of four to seventy
inputs which which happen to be in the
area kind of at random and they become
little features and then those features
are broadcast up the axon turns left and
right that's through this this set of
Purkinje cells you know and makes
contacts on some of the dendritic trees
about half of them about it's a 50%
probability than any axon makes a
contact and so you know we're talking
about is the brain this complicated is
this brain incomprehensible is it even
if you you know is it a thousand times
simpler it would still be
incomprehensible well this picture was
so such a draw to kind of an engineering
psyche back in the 1970s already David
Marv and James Albus separately said
okay we must be able to understand this
it's just this right it's even
rectangular I mean you know what we're
in biology do you find things that are
rectangular it's like a rectangular
interface it's so regular you have these
output neurons you have these there's
this massive number of feature detectors
you know it must be comprehensible and
models have been built and you know so
like that's what's being shown here
these are kind of the inputs coming in
they're turned into these little
conjunctive features they're sent up
through many many of these cells which
which make contacts those contacts are
modifiable with plasticity rules that
are that are known so it has to be
possible to understand this machine now
one of the missing pieces is what is one
Purkinje cell this huge dendritic tree
is it some complicated hierarchical
logical processor or or what actually
let me ask you when you look at those
pictures do you feel that that neuron is
probably a more complicated processing
device than some of the other neurons
does that make you feel that or do you
not even doesn't
No okay good oh okay actually that's
interesting because the simplest way to
look at a big dendritic tree is like
what a tree is it's just it's or a root
system or a vasculature system it's
something that delivers something or
receive something from something like a
volume you know you have roots in the
ground that receive nutrients and it
doesn't matter that it's a complicated
shape it's just what you call it yeah an
antenna yeah okay there you go an
antenna is something again you create
surface area or you know it or and now
the in the brain it's an antenna for
information you know you can think of it
or a root system that's pulling in
information rather than nutrients so
maybe it isn't complicated but the other
hand it has a hierarchy to it and if you
start thinking about hierarchical things
in hierarchical circuits you might think
about logic circuits and maybe it's that
because they're very nonlinear they have
these there are nonlinearities in these
then you know that generate very
nonlinear events in these dendritic
trees so maybe it's something more
complicated well anyway there's this
page right I only found this not too
long ago but basically well Martin Albus
both thought for completely engineering
reasons that these cells should act like
perceptrons they really should be big
linear summing devices and it turns out
this experimental paper and I think
there's at least one more that I found
basically says this is just a sum of
weighted inputs and they and they
actually did experiments and they quite
a bit it's a very it's a fun paper to
read and so okay now maybe that's maybe
we have an answer that that neuron
despite its visual complexity is
actually about the simplest thing that
you could possibly describe as a as an
integrative unit in the brain I don't
know if I would put bet my life that
this is the whole story but it may be
you know it may be really all we need to
know I don't know so that's kind of
interesting that even that some neurons
may have a very very simple description
I actually want to just call attention
to something about a Purkinje cell
because I'm now going to jump to a
different kind of cell and make a
different kind of argument this is a
tree I took a picture of this on the way
over here this morning it's actually
kind of similar at some level that
terrestrial trees that the kind
outside they have this property like
Purkinje cells of having kind of big
trunks that become a little bit less big
a little bit less big a little bit less
bigger then you have lots and lots and
lots of twigs they have a lot of surface
area kind of up here like this and the
same is true of a Purkinje cells so they
have a particular organization Purkinje
cells are kind of more like terrestrial
trees in this respect now there are
other types of neurons and I'm gonna get
that don't have that at all and they're
kind of the opposite of that and I'm
gonna I'm gonna show that in a second
but before we get there I just want to
start building up this this
kind of slide which will capture what
what sort of sequences ever more complex
models might be appropriate to use this
is just saying here's a cell here two
dendrites there's four inputs on these
two dendrites and the abstraction that
would be applied to a point neuron or a
Purkinje cell which basically acts like
the world's mother of all point neurons
is just that all the inputs are added
together and then they go to the spike
generating mechanism of the axon which
could be nonlinear or not and it's so
it's the simplest possible thing so
that's that's that now let's accept that
that's a point neuron other types of
neurons have very different morphology
and I said almost the opposite where
most of the synaptic contacts are not on
little tiny twigs which are sort of very
hierarchically deep in in the in the
cells dendritic tree but they're kind of
the opposite most of the synapses are on
long thin unbranched terminal dendrites
more and let me let me show you some of
the consequence of that so if that's
true then this point neuron hypothesis
starts to become less feasible okay
there are problems with it here is a a
pyramidal neuron and you can see what
what I meant when I said long unbranched
terminal sections you see these long
dendrites they go hundreds of microns
and some many of them don't branch over
that time some of them most of the
branching occurs closer to the cell body
and then you have longer runt branch and
actually this this unbranched in this
and the longus of them is something that
increases when you get for example in
humans I just saw a group where I think
it may be
Dutch group and you Don say gathers
working with them does anyone
I'm talking about okay and they were
they were they were looking at the human
neurons right and they found human
neurons are like extreme neurons and
they're extremely in this sense - they
have many many dendrites very long kind
of unbranched okay so that's the
opposite sort of tree like structure
than the Purkinje cell now the thing
about that sort of architecture for a
cell is that because of cable theories
so if you take a long kind of neural
cable these are coaxial cables they have
a conducting inside and a conducting
outside the extracellular medium and
then you have this insulator the the
cell membrane they you know you have you
have attenuation you have interesting
voltage conduction and current
conduction effects and it's very
asymmetric so here's a current being
injected this is a model a current being
injected into the middle of this
dendrite and here's the depolarization
the voltage signal here would be zero or
you know the the resting potential so
there's a significant depolarization at
that point and the the the the
attenuation of olders moving outward is
almost nothing so voltages are conveyed
very asymmetrically very well going
outward and there's a very steep
attenuation of a voltage signal going
inward so what this means is that
voltage signals out on the dendrites are
largely you know made tiny by the time
you get to the cell body so that voltage
signal and one dendrite is not felt very
much in another dendrite so kind of
there's voltage privacy provided by this
architecture of having a big lump a low
resistance lump in the middle which is
difficult to depolarize because it takes
a lot of current and having thin
dendrites emanating from them where
voltage signals are easy to produce but
are then suppressed as they approach the
cell body this does not mean that the
that a an input a good distance out in a
dendrite cannot have an effect on the
cell body in fact its effect on the cell
body despite this attenuation is is
quite mild leaf sensitive to location on
here and that's just because as you move
further out yes there's more and more
attenuation but the signal that is
generated locally is actually larger to
begin with so they kind of cancel out
and you have a relatively small
attenuation of current flowing towards
the cell body but you have good
to privacy that's yes generation comes
from the fact that the current is
flowing away through the soma so that
linear ramp of voltage basically but
isolated at the other end well the way
that the best way to understand this
asymmetry is to draw a circuit so draw a
cable like the simplest thing you could
imagine this is sort of a cable with no
capacitors in it but it's just it's an
RC circuit but I took the C's out and
let's say here's the here's the place
that I then I dejected a current in the
middle and here's the soma right here
and here's the the tip of the dendrite
right here so I have axial resistance
and then I have membrane resistance and
this is a compartmentalized
representation of the capable of okay
this is what's inside can compartmental
models so if you the soma has a lot of
membrane so there's a lot of parallel
membrane conductance and if you took
that to an extreme you'd say it's an
infinite amount of conductance which
basically means this becomes a wire and
then if you at the tip there's very
little there's no place for the current
to go so you can kind of abstract that
as this and if you do that and you were
to inject a current here then you get a
graph that looks like this you know V
here V here and zero there so that's
kind of like a cable reductio ad you
know unless the absurdum but ad perfecta
minimalistic whatever I don't have my
baton my Latin isn't as good as it
should be okay that's kind of that
picture except for backwards I should
anyway voltage privacy was it was the
point that I wanted to make now this
this I want to do a an acknowledgment
Christophe caulk back in 1983 made this
point and this was one of the early
computer modeling studies of neurons
there were some in the 70s at all
actually even Rahl I think in the 60s
was running
was sixties and seventies there's a
little couple things going on very
exotic
Kristof clock and poggio and Tory they
had the study and they basically
quantified the degree to which you could
expect to get voltage privacy within a
dendritic tree and they kind of made up
some criteria so okay if I if I'm if I'm
in this little area the dendritic tree
then and I generate a signal then I want
to I want to identify all those places
where the voltage that reaches it is not
attenuated by more than a factor of two
or X or whatever it is and they would
find groups of inputs or places that
fulfilled that criterion of good
communication and then the other
criterion was that these so-called
subunits would have to have bad
communication to either to another
subunit and so by to kind of just
measuring the communication back and
forth between every two points in the
dendritic tree they showed that you
could think of the dendritic tree as
providing a kind of a set of many quite
well isolated voltage subunits and
that's what they call them the coleman
dendritic subunits and that was you know
this is back in 1983 so that's the first
thing that it doesn't look like a point
neuron because it looks like there's
it's not a neuron that has one voltage
that then triggers action potentials
it's one that has many voltages that are
different from each other and little
computations might go on there that's
that's actually part of what these guys
said was okay well these are
computational subunits and they're gonna
do operations and logic things and this
is going to be a logic Network and
kristoff cost particularly like the and
not operation where excitation would
come in an inhibition would come in and
veto it and that's a nonlinear operation
and that would happen all over the
dendritic tree he he proposed and and so
anyway it was it was sort of the
beginning of thinking about a neuron as
a multi compartmental a multi subunit
computer okay so that's point point
number one and actually this is a piece
of data this is an experiment recording
at the cell body is the blue trace and
recording at the dendrite is red so then
stimulation of synapses is done by
releasing sucrose which causes synaptic
release and synaptic activity activity
and so you're gonna see some
to get activity on the dendrite the red
guy is really close to it so he's gonna
see more like the dendritic potential
which is going to be you know swinging
up and down bigger here you can see and
then this one's gonna see the somatic
potential which is very attenuated as we
as we just saw in that previous slide
and then they just looked at the ratio
you know how big is the swing here
versus how big is the swing here every
time there's a release event and this is
the ratio so if you get a hundred 50
microns out then the responses are forty
times larger than they are the felt at
the cell body so and and this is sort of
showing that attenuation curve but it's
a real experiment so the real neuron
really does obey cable theory which is
reassuring okay I have not ever seen an
example where we all neuron does not
obey cable theory they're really good
blue cables on a really good little RC
circuits and boy hodgkin and huxley
nailed it with you know their model i
mean it's amazing yeah well okay that's
my next point
nmda spikes I told you okay so problem
two so problem one is okay if you're
talking about is our neurons point
neurons problem one is well they're
clearly have multiple separate voltage
signaling domains that doesn't seem very
point neuron like second problem is that
inside those two main question is what
goes on inside those domains maybe
nothing maybe they could have voltage
privacy but they don't use it but it
turns out that dendrites of at least is
some kinds of neurons and pyramidal
neurons ours are among those types of
neurons have local spikes that get
generated inside those voltage private
places so here's a cell body this is a
dendrite sticking out here's one of
these long unbranched dendrites it's
filled with the calcium indicator that
kind of glows and then what's being done
here is that a laser a UV laser is shot
down at this slice the liquid the fluid
the extracellular fluid contains a
chemical called a Caged glutamate it
included main is the neurotransmitter
that would normally activate synapses
your excitatory synapses but it's it's
got a caged compound so it can't really
be glutamate but then when the laser
hits it unque jiz and suddenly there's a
little puff of glutamate right in the
location you get a synaptic activity and
that's that's this so you can kind of
create fake synaptic activity by pulsing
with a laser at different points and get
get little excitatory postsynaptic
potentials and so they did that and they
they would hit the laser a little harder
a little harder a little harder and then
suddenly boom the spike would be
generated and that's this kind of this
sort of a Sigma little curve you know a
gradual increase and then a big jump
when a threshold was crossed and a
certain number a certain amount of
excitation impinged on that dendrite and
that that that's called an NMDA spike I
don't show here but when they blocked I
guess I just didn't have the the curve
when they blocked this nm DN I'm gonna
talk about it in a second
nmd eight channels the spikes were
completely abolished now maybe does
anybody do you think it would be good
Brunell maybe that's your opinion I
could well maybe I could just use a
slide I didn't know this is a little bit
dry but in my people were spending just
one minute
talking about NMDA channels because
they're so important to to neurons so
why do you get a spike okay I think what
NMDA is is it's the these are nmds a
chemical that that that is like
glutamate but activates only a certain
type of synaptic receptor that's excited
to reenter Ahn's and almost every
synapse and every excitatory synapse or
many excitatory synapses in the central
nervous system are glutamate synapses or
most of them and most of those will have
NMDA channels they'll be act they'll be
activated there certain subtype and
these these channels have a have a very
they're they are they are they allow
that they have a nonlinear voltage
dependent property that allows them to
generate spikes when enough of them are
activated locally there's a regenerative
voltage spike generated not exactly like
an action potential in a neuron but you
know following similar kinds of
mechanisms I actually think it might not
be worth going over this but I you know
if we can accept that neurons generate
action potentials and we obviously can
accept that just maybe for the purposes
of not delving too much into detail but
I'd be happy to talk about this later is
that if you activate a sufficient number
of these glutamatergic synapses on a
dendrite the dynamics of the branch
change in such a way that the that there
is a this new stable fixed point a
voltage that will be produced by that
local piece of dendrite and the the
where as a small input will not generate
a spike a large input will and then of
course it saturates in height and so
this is this is sort of what's on just
absolutely covering the dendrites as if
parameter neurons are our NMDA channels
and there are other types of glutamate
channels as well but these these
dendrites are sitting there waiting to
be activated strongly and when they are
they can generate local spikes and send
the these big bonuses of current to the
cell body much more current gets sent to
the cell body than if that dendrite is
stimulated in a sub-threshold way if not
not sufficient input to true
respects so they are very nonlinear
branches this just a case of
depolarization on blocking the magnesium
block of the channel and the reason I
say we often think of spikes are
self-regenerating this is not a self
regenerating spike it's just a big it
gives because you don't want the chair
no it is definitely regenerative so what
happens here okay I'll just I'll just
take a second here
so the the if we had a linear if we an
NMDA channel would be represented like
this here's the the conductance and
here's the battery and the battery is by
luck for my graph here has a value of
zero it means anyway without dwelling on
that this is how one would represent an
NMDA channel in parallel across the
membrane and if if G nmda were a
conventional resistor then the voltage
current relationship would be a line now
this is let's call this the resting
potential of minus 70 millivolts of the
cell if you had activated this channel
if it became a non zero conductance and
the membrane potential which is this
axis we're minus seventy at rest then
because this is 0 and this is minus 70
which is more negative you would have
inward current flowing and you'd have a
lot of it like this now the thing is
about this channel is that as the
membrane potential becomes more negative
this channel becomes blocked and so it's
IV curve takes a turn and heads back
towards zero like that exactly
so in these negative potentials rather
than acting like a resistor just gets
clogged up by magnesium and it creates
this weird place here where unlike Ohm's
law which says the more voltage you
apply across the resistor the more
current flows through this is the less
voltage you apply across the resistor
because you're moving toward zero on the
V axis the more current will flow so
it's becoming like a negative resistance
and that's that's or a positive feedback
it's a little bit like you know taking
the gas pedal out of your car and
putting it on the front bumper and then
stepping on it which I don't recommend
towards you can push the camera anyway
so that's kind of and what happens here
is that anyway this this this diagram
will take five minutes to walk through
basically as the NMDA conductance
increases this basically if a scaling of
that IV curve and when finally it gets
to a high enough conductance that it
scrapes just below the thing that's
opposing it which is the leak then
suddenly the new thing the fixed point
jumps suddenly from a low place a low
voltage to a high voltage and that is
this regenerative mechanism that
generates the spike no no it's not non
decrement only propagating okay that's
that's a very good point let me let me
go back to I'll go to my next picture
but what what you would what you were
referring to and this is a very well
this is a very good point actually I'm
very glad you brought this up this is a
plate this is a spiking mechanism which
when synapses are activated near enough
to each other and enough of them a local
voltage spike will result however the
conditions for generating that spike do
not exist at other places along that
branch where synapses are not being
activated so unlike an action potential
if you start an action potential right
here in your big toe it'll just mean you
know goes right up to your brain it just
keep each section of the axon keeps
triggering the next section so the
conditions do exist for each section
along an action on a generator action
potential but on a dendritic tree it's
only where synapses are being activated
potentially sparsely that you have the
condition for generating a spike so it
does not actively propagate the voltage
signal will passively propagate but not
actively propagate it doesn't go undec
remanded down the cable so this is a
this is again it's something that
encourages privacy it says there'll be a
spike locally and and that'll be some
local threshold crossing which is a kind
of a computational operation but what
flows to the cell body is not a is it
does not encourage spike generation in
other dendrites yes yes they do the
voltages travel really well outward as I
showed on our previous slide so yes
it by the way I didn't even say what
this was this is just another experiment
in another group Jeff McGee's group
where they now they very accurately
activated different spines with
glutamate by uncaging and they would
kind of activate two of them for them
six of them eight ten twelve and then
suddenly there would be a spike
generated and as shown here so that's
this is a hippocampal parameter on the
other one was a neocortical pyramidal
neuron and and dendritic spikes have
been recorded in vivo these are
recordings in visual cortex a rat was
being I think was a rat or a mouse I
think maybe the mouse was being active
stimulated visually with bars in front
of its eyes and they were recording from
mrs. Spencer Smith with Michael Heizer
slab they were recording from dendrites
of these cells and generating these
spike like responses these big fat would
look like NMDA spikes with little sodium
spikes on top of them in the dendrites
things they never saw the cell body
these spikes would so they they were
clearly dendritic specialized spiking
going on in vivo as part of the response
of a neuron to a sensory stimulus and
here's a picture of spikes being
generated in the hippocampus in vivo
this is an awake animal running down a
virtual track and these are calcium
recordings you know from little bits of
dendrites this is from again Tom Beck's
lab and here you can show four
recordings and four dendrites
simultaneously and there would be
occasions when this is the cell body
there are occasions where the cell body
generates a response and none of the
dendrites do there's occasions where the
dendrite here's a dendrite that
generates a response and there's nothing
significant at the cell body and
sometimes they all go together so
there's an independence of dendritic
spiking from somatic spiking they to to
support the idea that a cell is a multi
compartmental nonlinear thing yes this
pointing towards a need in some neurons
for
input activation is appointed to a need
for non-linear input activations well
it's this is really more statement of
what device the input see when they land
you know if you put a sufficient if you
if you at turn up stimulation to one
compart one subunit you get a modest
output until finally you get a threshold
crossing and then you get a large output
so i guess i would just call it a little
sigmoid Almirall network unit almost
that's what we're talking about so far
and and then the the inputs can use that
as they see fit you know the brain build
circuits and so on i also point out and
this was something that kind of
surprised me that even inhibitory
interneurons this is dendrites of
inhibitory interneurons they were
activated in another in a clustered way
which is a good way to generate a strong
stimulus versus is distributed and found
that that when you clustered the inputs
you had a much larger response than the
hold on this is I think this is a PV
maybe it's maybe just clusters vs.
distributed anyway they found that there
was a super linear response when the
inputs were when the inputs were
clustered and and this was consistent
with with oh yeah here we go AP 5 AP 5
is a blocker of NMDA channels yeah
that's what the blue one is here so when
the inputs are clustered and they're not
NMDA channels are not blocked you have a
kind of a linear increase in the
response and then there's a super linear
increase which is what's produced by the
NMDA channels spring loading and they
create a kind of a stereotyped you know
voltage spike that's a stereotyped
height and that generates a lot of
current if you block NMDA channels you
get a small fraction of the current at
the cell body it's it may be the case
that it that the parameter runs don't
fire unless there are NMDA spikes in in
vivo it could be the case or they don't
fire much or they're not requiring
strongly ever unless unless these events
are going off it could be yeah
neurons having your camera or something
like this no god but they inhibitory
neurons release Kappa yeah but they
could be they can be excited so you have
to excite them in order to make them
fire in order for them to the release
inhibitory coming from the granular
cells those are excited to reimpose
although Purkinje cells don't have NMDA
channels so that's kind of that sort of
fits with what we're saying because we
said the Purkinje cell is a big
perceptron and it doesn't split it's not
supposed to be taking little bits of
this dendrite and making a little local
subunit nonlinear thresholding
computations supposed to be just doing a
big grand sum of everything and so you
don't want NMDA channels and they don't
have that I'm sure if they did have them
I would have been able to come up with a
story why they should have them but are
there other knows that don't have a
channels was that kind of well Notre
Dame well let's see so I it's it's I
think it's very unusual to not have them
if you had glutamate glutamatergic
synapses for example in the striatum
those those the spiny medium spiny
neurons they have NMDA channels and they
have NMDA I think I'm just blanking I
think it just saw I got I apologize
whoever just showed me this but I think
that they generate NMDA spikes too or
NMDA nonlinearities they have that this
is another but but so to answer your
question I think it's unusual to not
have it so a Purkinje cell may be an
outlier in being a big linear neuron
it's an outlier in multiple respects
it's you know it's like so anyway
you know what I'm gonna skip this it's
making the same point again this is this
is the work of from antic surgeon antek
they were using voltage sensitive dyes
and I actually know this speaks to a
slightly different issue which I'm gonna
point to we you know when we when we
want to build up an abstraction of what
the neuron is okay now we're kind of we
except we saw that there's a biophysical
basis for saying that there would be
voltage
halation between branches because
signals are attenuated strongly as they
move towards the cell body the voltage
signals are attenuated strongly see
voltage privacy so we said that and then
we pointed to we pointed to the fact
that these branches can generate spikes
this is a this graph here shows you when
you generate a spike in one dendrite
what does it look like in another and
that's that's shown here so here the
release of glutamate is occurring at
locations five and six and these are
these are voltage sensitive dyes
responding and you see this big response
at locations five and six as you move
down towards the cell body the magnitude
of the response that's that big slow
NMDA spiking response is very attenuated
now what happens is as a result of the
current that's generated by this thing
that flows to the cell body the cell
body generates two action potentials and
a later a little bit later those action
potentials are back propagated and you
can see little versions of them on top
of the slow spike that generated them
but then in the other branch branch
where is it
positions seven eight and nine which is
on a different dendrite wait a second
where am i oh here we go 789 you don't
see any sign of that sub-threshold spike
you just see the somatic action
potentials so that's that's it that's
right there on this on this this slide
the the sort of demonstration of the
isolation this is another one where
spikes are generated in this part of a
parameter on dendrite and I'm sorry
there's two recordings red and blue and
spikes can be generated at either on
either of those dendrites with these
electrodes and when they were you could
have a big blue spike but then measured
at the red electrode there's all there's
very little or you could generate a
spike on this dendrite and have a big
response and have very little on the
blue electrode so this is again showing
the combination of local spiking and
good voltage isolation within one neuron
yes
well I mean an NMDA spike kind of by
definition means there's a large NMDA
conductance now why could that be well
without any inputs well it's sort of a
little bit of an oxymoron because that
isn't in I mean its glutamate has to be
bound now could you have spontaneous
release you know weird like background
activity the when you say no input you
might mean like no like nothing
interesting and but somehow a bunch of
axons happen to fire at the same moment
and and a spike is generated yes that
can't happen and in any experiments
people will in slices sometimes report
that they just see a spike happen and
they didn't do anything it doesn't mean
that something couldn't happen but they
didn't mean to do it
okay so that's that's that now here's
the sort of the summary of this if
primal or in dendrites and by this I
mean neurons that have long thin on
branched terminal sections with lots of
NMDA channels on them which is a lot of
neurons generate local spikes and act
like separately threshold to
compartments
shouldn't we thinking about a
multi-layered model of a neuron in other
words something like this where you have
the cell body but instead of just adding
everything it adds things you know with
with their own little local integrative
units and one branch is one unit that
that's that that's an abstraction it's
an oversimplification probably but is
this not a better model to adopt and so
here's an experiment that tests that
hypothesis you know in a very direct way
in the most controlled way that well
that we could think of this was
something this was in collaboration with
Jackie Schiller you have two inputs
you're gonna put them either together on
one branch or you're gonna put them on
two branches and look at the difference
and here input a was generating a little
epsp the black trace B generates another
black trace blue is the sum of them so
that's what you would expect if it was
kind of a linear unit summing and red is
what you actually got when you applied
both inputs together and it looks linear
for a weak input so just a few spines
being activated by the two individual
inputs now if you get a little bigger
input a and B a little bit bigger than
here now blue is a little
because you've had more total sum of
these two but now a spike is generated
clearly a super linearity and if you
were to send in really big inputs now
these are almost probably spike like
events in and of themselves and so the
sum is large but the actual thing is you
know there's a saturation effect going
on and so the actual voltage response is
not linear leaves it's a sub linear sub
linear effect and if you look at here's
the expected what you're supposed to get
by kind of the linear assumption and
what you actually get for weak inputs
that you sort of do get what you expect
red equals blue and then you get a super
linear thing and then if you keep going
you can get saturation you can kind of
go below the line of linearity and get a
sub one anything now this pattern is
exactly what you'd expect for two things
adding up underneath the sigmoid you
sort of have a linear part at the
beginning and then it goes super linear
and then they go to sub one here and
then the control experiment is to do the
exact same experiment with with inputs
on two branches now you get something
that's close to linear in all cases and
that is shown that data shown here at
least we can say that summation between
two branches is very different than
summation within a branch and a branch
it looks it looks like it's obeying a
sigmoidal Thresh holding on us on a
linear sum of the two inputs and this
just looks like a linear sum so that's
that supports the idea that sub units
are nonlinear
they have non-linear is a little
threshold and then they add at the soma
a two layer model
we're gonna about to take a break or
okay so yeah well let's get to just the
end of this little bit so I just want to
point out that two layer models are very
interesting we all know that a two layer
model you have a layer of nonlinear
operations and then you have another
layer is a in principle a universal
computer and so it's it's a or it's
certainly a more powerful processing
device then I want you know then a big
linear sum with with the threshold stuck
on the end of it and and and
interestingly a lot of cells there's a
lot of literature in the brain that
where cells have been recorded from and
they look like to layer models at least
the way they've been described by the
neurophysiologist who've recorded from
them in sensory experiments and so on as
to their models where you have some kind
of receptive field subunits that appear
to be summed in inside the neuron and
you know we we've thought for well
here's any you know maybe maybe the
subunits receptive field subunits
actually correspond to dendritic
subunits and this is a hypothesis that
we've been sort of entertaining for a
long time and hoping turns out to be
true here's an example of a type of
sensory receptive field subunit these
were experiments by Hubel and Wiesel
this wasn't their paper this is a
textbook presentation but they recorded
from cells that had these vertical or
oriented light dark filters essentially
almost like linear filters that liked an
oriented bar here or an oriented edge
here or here or here or here it's not
over a larger receptive field and they
postulated that maybe the neuron which
responds to any of these positions and
therefore seems to be a sum of these non
linear subunits or threshold and
separately thresholded subunits they
that that's a perfect example of a two
layer model and what in interesting I
found a comment from 1982 by David Hubel
he said one has to consider the
possibility that in the monkey the
simple cell step which of those sort of
individual receptor you know kind of
spatially localized receptive fields I
was pointing to may be skipped perhaps
by summing the inputs from let cells
sort of the precursor cells on the
dendrites of complex cells in such a
scheme each dendritic branch
of a complex all would perform the
function of the simple cell so he kind
of you know maybe anticipated in 1982
that maybe there could be dendritic
subunit ization that is accounting for
the cell unitization of receptive fields
okay so I mean I I'm gonna go back to
this thing and what we'll get we'll have
a break here
but here's where we got we got from here
the point neuron but four major classes
of neurons pyramidal neurons are the are
80 percent of the neurons in your
cerebral cortex and your febrile cortex
is like ninety percent of the mass of
your brain so it's a big category
including all of its connections so this
is that the two layer model basically
says no it's not like that it's like
this you have individual dendritic
branches you have a bunch of them there
they are little summing units kind of
like an old point neuron but now that
point neurons are the dendrites and the
dendrites feed into the cell body where
they're where the results are added
potentially with weights who knows and
then then that goes to the axon to
produce the output of the neuron so it's
it's something kind of isomorphic to a
neuron in a neural network or or a two
layer neural network essentially but
within one neuron and I'm just going to
leave a I'm gonna leave a little note
here that it's going to explain why
we're going to find that this is also
not right it's it's wrong in an
interesting way and there's going to be
an elaboration which which which does a
better job of capturing which is even
more interesting and that's where when
we come back we can we can pick up there
any questions before we break yeah
meaning that would these be negative
weights that is not likely these weights
this is sort of I'm putting this here
kind of to make it look like a neural
network but really what it is is as a
branch connected into the cell body the
currents that are generated by NMDA
channels are excited to recurrence so
that's not likely to be part of the
abstraction of a parameter on as far as
I can tell now there can be indirect
effects where currents that go into the
cell body that depolarize it turn on
channels that oppose that depolarization
like potassium channels but you wouldn't
still call that a negative weight it
doesn't push it downward so I would say
no that's part of the asymmetry of
neurons you know with respect to
excitation in addition that you don't
have at a neural network that this
weight actually shouldn't be able to be
negative and most most of the contacts
are also positive even on to the
individual dendrites there's an
overwhelming majority of positive
contacts in the brain and positive
contacts do not turn into negative
contacts when you do with the learning
rule yes I'm not understanding something
like McCulloch and Pitt's pointed out
that if you don't have negative inputs
you have a monotone circuit and you
can't do anything with that well you can
you can certainly do things I mean okay
I'm not saying that there isn't
inhibition in the brain but if so for
example this device if we only have
excitatory weights could function as a
bunch of these could function like and
gates because they have their son with a
threshold and then this could be
essentially a sum of a but or these
could be like products and this is a sum
of product so ya know we can we can well
if you if you believe that the right way
to build up the function of the brain is
many layers of NAND gates which is in
principle a universal computer I agree
then you do want an and but you it's not
clear that that's the right way to
structure the computation so let's
the inputs are how can you get an output
when the when there's no input right are
you saying how can you make a neuron
responds when it has no input well you
could certainly have a breasting firing
rate what a resting firing rate and but
then according to this model would just
keep on keep on having a firing so there
are places in the brain such as the
cerebellum where cells have a high
resting rate and because and they're
arresting even though all of the
synaptic modification axes are
excitatory for moments a moment the
total synaptic drive can fluctuate up
and down and so the rate can move both
ways around a resting potential so
that's one way of getting something
that's below expectation is having
setting a high resting rate and that is
done in the cerebellum that is not done
in the cortex so we maybe what you
should maybe the question that I'm
trying to the question I'm trying to get
is which computation cannot be
accomplished and but but we also we
don't the question that we're trying to
ask here is not can I find a computation
that's inconvenient for neurons and the
answer will be yes but what we're really
trying to do is we're trying to look at
a neuron figure out what it can do well
and then figure out how it is using that
capability to solve the problems that it
actually does solve you know there's
there's lots of computations that will
not be particularly well represented by
a neuron but you know I just don't see
how a person without inputs you know
complete d'art no inputs and wait up
okay so like I said you can so that's
interesting you said dark because in the
retina in the dark the cells are
maximally activated and they there's a
there's a dark current and that current
is shut off by light so you can the
polarities of things can be switched and
are switched okay you know what I I
think I'm getting it I'm what I just
said to you is that the brain is very
happy to create opposite polarity
channels that represent the opposite
thing for example in the retina we have
on cells
we have off sells an on sell response to
the increase in light and an off cell
response to a decrease in light and so
opposites polarity channels can be
created explicitly and they are
represented by positive firing rates
both but they represent firing rate can
can can represent an increase and a
positive firing rate in a different cell
can represent a decrease so oftentimes
we brain splits variables into opponent
channels which represent the to the
positive of the negative of some
variable or you can have a high resting
rate and it can go down it can go up so
there's different tricks that the brain
can play to represents a positive and
negative quantities or up and down
changes so the connections from the sub
units to the soma don't have any vision
yes if these are positive and all these
can in fact yeah all right and now all
the inputs to dendrites are not all
positive they are they do include in
addition and I'm going to talk about
that a little while but yes you can't
yes this is a limited this is a computer
which has certain powers and not others
[Applause]
[Music]